how is everyone today ah my job as a  director is I get to dream for a living  Michael you know you're known for such  unbelievable action what inspires you  how do you come up with these  unbelievable ideas I create visual  worlds that are so beyond everyone's  normal life experiences and Hollywood is  a place that creates a viewer escape and  what I try to do is I as a director I  try to the type is all off sorry but  I'll just witness tell us what you think  yeah we'll just wing it right now i  taked i try to take people on an  emotional ride and the curve how does it  how do you think it's going to impact  how're you has experienced your movies  excuse me I'm sorry I'm sorry okay  ladies gentlemen let's thank michael bay  for joining us  you